إنها يد جيدة والدعائم
أخبرنا أن يتغير كل عام
بحيث تكون جميلة مشرقة مثل
مصدر الذهب هذا الجسر الملقى باللوم
عمل من برج الإنكا دير بعد
نحن لسنا فخورون بحسابك
[موسيقى]
الرجل بداخل أي من
تابيا وأنا أخاطب الناس
وحتى النظر إلى التاريخ لم يحثوا عليه
الله مهندس البناء نحن اثنان
ذكور أنا من الجانب الأيمن
لقد بدأت وفي هذا الجانب حيث لا يوجد التاريخ
هذا الجسر طبيعي ولا نستخدمه
أو المسامير الأسمنتية من أي نوع
وبالتالي تخلى الجهاز عن المزيد من جهة
نحن فقط نربط كل عام دائمًا
نقوم بالأسابيع الثانية من شهر يونيو
يتكون الجسر من أربعة صلبة
اثنين من الدرابزين الجسر 38 مترا
يجب على كل مشارك إحضار 40
السكتات الدماغية الإجبارية المعروفة
من المفترض أن تصل إلى التردد
نفعل ذلك بقطع قطع
أجنحة الأوسكار من تشان التجفيف
الاستيلاء على الأرض بحيث أ
قليلا لينة وبعد ذلك لدينا جميعا
العمل بالماء نضع الحبل معًا
ونحن نلف في المحفظة في الطباشير
نقوم بالدفع كله مطلوب من
الدعائم للإجازة ثم ل
start أيضًا لا يزال يدفع
الأرض ثم لجان التسعير ذلك
لا شيء يمكن أن يحدث دعنا نذهب
اجعل الرجال الأقوياء يتقدمون لاحقًا
لقد بدأنا للتو في فك الجسر
في وقت لاحق نتحدث عندما من الصفيح
شوتا
إذا سمحوا لك
الاتفاق يحدث هو أن الناس لديهم
خائف
سيود العصبي و يكون
نجاح
ثم نبدأ في التضفير
نفتتح دائما الرقص الغنائي
لذلك نفتتح في النهاية عندما ننتهي
أنا أحب الجسر كثيرا الآن
فخور إذا لم أكن سعيدًا بماذا
يتغيرون
وأنا أقوم بما يقرب من 40 عامًا أيضًا
جدي سيحب ذلك أيضًا بعد ذلك
من جدي وأبي وأنا
البريطانيون من المتابعة إلى الأبد
سنبقى دائما
سميث وأنت ستكون أستاذي هو التماسك
القصة مع هذه القصة وتضعنا
حياة طويلة فخور
[موسيقى]